[Music]
[Music]
all right it's 6:10 we're out of the
campsite we've got everything but the
tent put away they steal the tent who
cares wish me love no all right guys
7:20 in the morning we are going
sturgeon fishing all right guys we're
here a fishing guide Steve came with
sturgeon hunters calm and we are gonna
go get some bait fish first and we're
gonna climb the food chain here and
this'll be fun
right now we're not theirs
look at this spot this is beautiful
folks what we're doing is we're cruising
around and we're looking for these
little fish about a 10 inch fish called
northern pike minnow formally referred
to as a [ __ ] fish we're gonna catch
some bait and once we got some bait then
we go sturdy excellent
that is a northern pike minnow aka all
right there we go
there you go Tommy got northern pike me
too I catch a sturgeon with him check it
out right there they're just popping all
over the place hmm beautiful little fish
look at that good job look at him
well we got about 20 or 30 of these
northern pike minnow caught up so we
have got bait for two days and now we're
gonna go get ourself some surgeons Tommy
and Nate are well entertained though
show me your crazy dance guys
[Music]
basically a live bait right you're just
not good taste okay guys we just saw two
more jump a little one in like a six
foot plus sturgeon jump out of the water
it's like I'm on a whale watching tour
this is this is insane I'm just I'm
getting so pup you got it's not like
carpet no bow - I'm the real truth when
he goes from side to side do with a low
rod position that's it just hang on to
American it's a dinosaur we're catching
a dinosaur what do you think they're
thrilled
that's uh that's high fives probably
just a touch under six foot that's a
hundred pound fish right there sweet
that's what we call a good start
hey he's got another hook in him yeah he
does yeah he does where others have
failed we succeeded yeah he's good to go
just turn them sideways they'll swim
away thank you very much that's a start
that's a great fish
whoo my back's tired I'm an old man an
old fat man just another gorgeous spot I
don't think there's too many ugly spots
it's part of the river look what I found
Aviva puffs give it a shot it's like a
Girl Scout cookie and a peep had a baby
[Music]
in the fork of the tip 102 inches eight
and a half feet holy mackerel
that is eight and a half feet of stirred
eight and a half foot probably 325 to
350 pounds
[Music]
haha
behind a half feet man that was awesome
whoo that was fun
Tommy is celebrating with some bubbles
here all right we're here in another
beautiful spot and not too far from the
shore here just got a drop off you know
that mouth comes out there's no T's in
there at all you put your hand right in
his mouth you touch his tongue what
touches tongue feel hard this is
[Music]
well we've caught three awesome sturgeon
two around five feet and one at eight
and a half feet that's what I call a
full day but we have utterly destroyed
Steve's boat here
it's all sorts of chocolate and dirty
diapers and who knows what else we'll
have to love to clean this up really
well but uh we're gonna call it a day
today
it just so happens that I have some
sturgeon caviar right here this little
can right here was 96 Canadian dollars
and we're gonna try it I've eaten a lot
of fish eggs I've eaten flying fish eggs
Cod eggs salmon eggs I've never eaten
sturgeon eggs though so this is gonna be
a first for me we're gonna try this out
so that's the farm surgeon this is
there's a 1 land-based fish farm that
raises white sturgeon they're originally
from Fraser River stock they started
probably 15 years ago 15 16 years ago
13 years before they had got big enough
to get a crop see if I could even get
this jar open oh-ho-ho looks kind of
like poppy seeds or something there we
go not a strong flavour to salmon that
ceremonies are I don't like them um I
like little overpowering format this is
one heck of a way to celebrate my my
eight and a half foot white sturgeon by
eating its babies little fishies all
right I'm gonna wash the can up I think
I want to keep it you're perfect for
holding little bits of fishing tackle
well thanks loads of fun I will see you
tomorrow morning same bat time same bat
place all right we'll do it well let's
go back get some real food in Chilliwack
and then we'll head back to the camp and
maybe we'll go swimming you ready to go
swimmin all right let's do it
all right guys this is the cool you want
to go swimming
Oh take your boots off take your boots
up if you guys will go in and start
swimming around I'll join ya
I'm not going good I'm waiting right
here let's see you guys go I think the
only way we're going swimming is just
one of them falls in and gets wet guys
do you just want me to drag you into the
water okay you just did it that's the
worst part
what's got you you're holding on to me
you're touching the bottom yeah you know
it's a good outing when it ends with the
boys egging mama
under their breath all the time on our
way here to the campsite we found a lady
- with seven fresh raspberries and fresh
nectarines and they've been really good
want one bud well it's still pretty
light outside and the boys are still
pretty wired so we're gonna watch a
movie together on the Kindles and
hopefully by the time we're done it will
be a little bit darker and everyone will
be a little bit of sleep sure this kind
of goes against the spirit of camping
but if I can't have a campfire darn it
might as well watch a movie
we're awake up and out of our camp
before 6:00 a.m. well here we are it's
another beautiful morning and we're
ready for day two of sturgeon fishing
here on the Fraser River hello Nathan so
cute what I'm gonna do when he grows up
well guys we still have bait left over
from yesterday and our guide met a dude
in the back alley who hooked him up with
a couple grams of sockeye so we're gonna
take our eight ball of sockeye and our
other our other bait and we're gonna get
right to it today so we'll see what
happens I'm not sure how on earth we
could possibly top yesterday but the
Brady River can do it in a heartbeat if
it wants to so we'll see what happens
Namie you want to catch a big surgeon
thing
one two three four five six sighs not
one seven the sonar has been blowing up
lots of good marks on here so we're
gonna give it a go let it hit for about
30 minutes or so see what we get if we
like what we see great if not we'll move
on not a ripper jumper that's nice we
got that strike when I was in the middle
of putting jammies on Tom he was
complaining about being cold right in
the middle of it the worst time possible
Ron goes tap tap
honk and Tommy goes flying through the
air like a discarded article of clothing
he took it pretty well though but he
seems no worse for the wear that seemed
to warm him up well we got one fish out
of that hole but nothing much happened
after that so we're moving spots
pick up the rock pick up gently
[Music]
like a little bit of chocolate this fish
has more runs than a man who drinks
Mexican tap water
we're gonna need a bigger boat yeah
oh he put up a strong fight right on
right on the fork call me a - yeah
another 300 pound plus fish there you
gonna get a chance to pet a dinosaur
there we go fossil hunting their house
and we find fossilized sturgeon scoots
everyone's is that right yeah not
compared to this guy what I like to do
is just sort of hold them in the current
a little bit just let them feel that
current for a little bit look Tommy I
wet my pants guys I feel selfish
I feel selfish how many people never in
their life get to see or catch an
eight-foot sturgeon I'm gonna do it
twice man that's old Stevie Ray one joke
and he says he knows how to catch the
big boys that's a good fish that thing
was stronger I think the other one maybe
didn't tire itself out as much with the
jump in but that that put the hurt on me
a lot more than that first one so Steve
just told me that
Sturgeon right there the one we just
landed was the 50th fish they've caught
this year it was eight feet or longer
that's insane guys this is an amazing
amazing fishery
go to the COI wanna stay on top there is
now let him go you go about a six footer
all right
[Music]
[Music]
I feel something down there watching the
hook we caught three fish yesterday two
5-footers in the eight and a half footer
today we caught three six-footers a
5-footer
and 1/8 footer so if my Master's be
correctly that's 49 feet of sturgeon in
two days that's amazing
come here fight sturgeon in the straw
fraser river there's nothing like it and
if you guys want i'll put a lot more
information the steve kales guide
service sturgeon hunter calm i'll put it
in the description if you guys want to
see more information all right Steve
thanks again the pleasure all right
Nathan head back to the car or I'm going
to have to I'm gonna have to beat you
with a stick I'm gonna eat you Oh Nathan
you better catch up with Tommy I'm
coming for you my back is sore reeling
in eight sturgeon in two days it's a lot
of work what would you like to do our
last day here before we go see mom would
like to go out to a movie together well
maybe we should do that have either of
you guys ever been to a movie before no
I don't think you have but I don't think
you've ever been I don't think you know
what 3d is grab one of these special
glasses all right let's go into a movie
you excited for a 3d movie
five minute press I can't talk well guys
what what did you think of your first
movie Tommy where are your shoes but we
have enough where'd they go
my kid can't keep his shoes on well
let's go back to the campsite we're
gonna get a good night's rest and
tomorrow we're driving back to Vancouver
and we're gonna see mommy and Jacob
again are you guys excited
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go get mommy and Jacob so we're at
some random gas station in Vancouver
filling up and this crow comes up and is
like right in our business and I jumps
up on the car that's so crazy
oh you smell so much better than I do
family's all back together alright so we
got the crew loaded up we're gonna head
to the US border and we've got to find
someplace to stay tonight we have the
rest of today and most of tomorrow free
and we just we haven't played anything
we haven't booked anything we're just
playing it by ear well we got a little
time to kill and we blew through customs
so smoothly we're gonna go and check out
birch Bay State Park here in Washington
I think we grab some food are you hungry
Tom got a huckleberry soda here and a
honey cream daddy got himself his own
pizza to the car all right babe so we
got Maui Wowi which is like passion
fruit mango guava we got fruity pop
rocks
you guys should we go find a pretty spot
on the beach go walk the beat a little
bit yeah oh nice little blackberry oh
that is a good one oh look at all these
blackberry bushes well look at a ton of
em hmm well they got rose hips over
there look at this look at this sorry
this whole wall is just blackberries
look at this beach guys this is awesome
we just kind of kind of stumbled upon
this and this is gorgeous
thank you I found you a clam shell now
do you know how to look for live clams
not just dead ones look for a hold in
his hands see right here see this whole
scary hole
in there oh there he is
see him chase you always a crab you've
got a little crab oh look what I found
oh there's thousands of them oh yes it's
like this it's like an earwig but over
the ocean sound guys look how big it is
that crab must have been as big as your
guys's head come here check this out
this is a muscle that's a shellfish
called a muscle when they get bigger you
can eat them
that's a sandworm look at the seaweed
see you right here here we go pop pop
there's a clam there's a crab inside it
well guys I'm having a ball on this
beach the boys are to find all the
little critters and clams and stuff
that's a sand dollar think it's the legs
look at that shared our sea
it's pushing for 30 and we need to get
into a hotel and get these boys showered
I haven't had a shower and more days
than I like to admit these boys need to
get to bed at a reasonable time for once
I think Tommy just discovered that
walking barefoot on barnacle covered
rocks really hurts being a trooper about
it though I carry him back last hotel
stay of the trip here at the Holiday Inn
Express you're in someplace in
Washington I forgot swimming trunks
shouldn't we does it matter where in the
world you go or how much money you spend
the part the kids the enjoy the most is
playing in the pool
[Music]
well good morning folks and welcome to
the last day of our month-long trip so
this is what a hotel room looks like
after just one night yeah when we left
our home in Virginia it was June and it
is now August and we've caught fish all
over Utah and we've traveled to Japan
and seen and done wonderful things we've
shot machine guns in Las Vegas and raced
Lamborghinis now we're headed home but
we've had a good trip isn't that right
guys yeah yep
seven pieces of checked luggage two
strollers and about four carry-ons to
simply check my rearview mirror oh yeah
baby
[Music]
the house is burned down that's good we
are home it's about 2:30 in the morning
and it feels good to be home hopefully
you guys have enjoyed coming along for
the ride enjoyed all these videos if you
like this series you like watching this
type of videos make sure to click like
let me know you like it and leave a
comment tell me what your favorite part
was if you guys want to see more great
videos from that outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching guys I'm
gonna go get some sleep
it's been a long month
[Music]